grégoire rené nous écrit existe-t-il des
règles entourant les changements de
partis politiques par des candidats
pendant la campagne électorale
il fait évidemment référence à gertrude
bourdon qui a flirté avec la cac
avant de faire le saut avec un parti
libéral vient après vérification la loi
électorale permet un candidat de changer
d'allégeance politique en cours de
campagne tant que les choses sont faites
dans les règles de l'art c'est à dire
qu'un candidat qui aurait déjà déposé
son bulletin de candidature devrait donc
le retirer avant d'en déposer un nouveau
et ce faisant il devrait refaire toutes
les étapes préalables au dépôt d'une
candidature comme par exemple recueillir
une centaine de signatures d'électeurs
de sa circonscription
ce que n'a pas eue la fin gertrude
bourdon puisqu'elle n'a jamais été
officiellement candidate pour la cac
avant de se présenter pour le plq voilà
j'espère que ça répond à votre question
si vous en avez d'autres
écrivez nous à vous aux élections @
radio canada.ca